[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
stoicism concern and caring and we're
going to try to dispel some some myths
and some misconceptions about
stoic philosophy and practice which has
been getting more and more popular over
the last decade or so actually going
back even further than that dan and i
are both members of the milwaukee stoic
fellowship we're both co-organizers
of that group which is one of many
local stoic groups worldwide and you've
heard us talk if you've listened to this
radio show before about stoicism quite a
bit it's one of the main approaches that
that we
draw upon
both of us in in our practice and
thinking things through so when we talk
about
applying philosophy to life that's one
of the main ones that we do
so um i'm going to turn it over to dan
and let you sort of sort through
some of the
misconceptions about what it means to be
a stoic that that you've seen and you've
run into
by people who are kind of getting it
right and kind of getting it wrong
um what would you say is is uh well i
mean we can actually run through a whole
bunch of them but maybe we won't do that
today what would you say is one of the
biggest ones
um i guess the first thing is the idea
that stoicism
is just like a group of life acts and
not like a whole system um
and
people will grab certain things from
that there's lots of like really
interesting
nuggets that are part of the system that
are sometimes a little bit
counter-intuitive but people grab onto
them and they they might misconceive
that this is the whole of what stoicism
is
and one of the big ones that
is rather misconstrued as like
oh
the dichotomy of control kind of being
like the be all end-all and that's yeah
we're gonna we're gonna talk about that
in just a few minutes the dichotomy of
control is this notion that you
just stick to what you actually have
control over after you've managed to
identify it and forget about everything
else and
not really what the stoic does
[Music]
right
right so what about
people who use stoicism or they conceive
of it this way as a reason to
withdraw from other people to isolate
themselves to
try to insulate themselves from the rest
of the world i mean is that based in
anything or
is that um
like totally actually go ahead
it's totally
i'd say counter to
one of the major projects that stoicism
is trying to solve is how do you have a
good life while interacting with the
other people in the world
that the
the stoic is someone that is in the
world that is interacting daily and is
not you know cloistering themselves or
removing themselves from society you
know they're one of the the major
schools that they
uh had
rather
uh
opposing views to were the ep koreans
who
wouldn't you know they have this whole
idea of the garden and returning to the
garden and kind of walling yourself off
from
all the people that we have to deal with
in day to day because they're a cause of
of you know um being upset and and
they're like okay let's just like remove
all the things
um but
uh
the whole point of stoicism
is how do you maintain that calmness
that tranquility that equanimity
uh
and still actually be there for
for the other people and with the other
people yeah that's actually a great
point and the epicureans
um i mean we were missing some texts
actually almost all texts from them from
classical antiquity but it does look
like they actually did have a garden
and the whole point of it was to
withdraw from
society into this we could almost like
call it an ideal intentional community
obviously they must have had problems
and conflicts
in there and had to work them out but
what they they ended up doing is is uh
taking themselves out of
you know the ancients called it the
political sphere but we would call it
the social sphere and
you're right the stoics say no that's
not the way to go that's that's actually
counterproductive so
before we jump in and talk about what is
stoicism and you know some of the key
features of it
why do you think today there are
so many people and you see this in stoic
facebook groups or
other places people say oh but i thought
stoicism was about withdrawing myself
from anything that could potentially
bother me
where's that disconnect coming from do
you think
well as we touched on a little bit
earlier the the dichotomy of control is
one of the first things that is kind of
usually presented okay to people and
then and a lot of people when they first
enter into it that it's like
they
they don't know that this is
a piece that has to be supported by
other things like action
uh and uh your acceptance of things and
without the the rest of the pieces here
um this little this one thing can't
stand alone
yeah that's a good way to put it um so
we'll definitely be hitting on that in a
bit um we should
talk about what stoicism is just in case
anybody's confused and they're like hey
wait i i you know i know about somebody
being stoic means that stiff upper lip
thing
um we have something a bit different in
mind
now why do you say that
yes
i don't know partly i kind of um
associate it with the british oh and you
said the step up your lip so that's
where it kind of came from uh but
absolutely this uh
there's a
common colloquial usage and we usually
call this like little stoicism which is
um the the common usage of the term
nowadays and then there's big astosis
which is the actual philosophy of life
and i think we should
go in like what is the philosophy of
life and that is a a whole set of
mores and values
in which you can live a good life like
that that's the whole idea of
a
uh the stoic project as well as many of
the other um philosophical projects at
the time
where like how does one live a good life
yeah and
uh the whole idea within stoicism
there's there's a number of things that
we'll get into uh in which
the the the argument is if you follow
these things you're going to have a more
calm equinemeous um and
peaceful wife
yeah and and i think there's other
things that will
come out of that necessarily but the
stoics were willing to say well if you
don't get that that's okay like being
more productive in the workplace you
know so if you can calm your mind and
not get into unnecessary conflicts with
your boss with your customers with
suppliers with
your co-workers and you know whoever
else happens to show up at the ups
person you know delivering a package um
you'll you'll certainly go further right
you're going to get more done
but the goal is not simply to be a
better productive drone in getting
things done it's to
you know change who you are as a person
so that you hold on to the things that
are genuinely good and you slowly strip
away the things that although you might
be a little you know attached to them at
first turn out to be counterproductive
for you they turn out to be
bad and you're right all the ancient
philosophies that were philosophies of
life were doing that the epicureans had
their own schtick the cynics the uh
platonus and aristotelians even the
skeptics were about
doing something with yourself and and
they all had um like you said different
values that they were arranging
different texts different arguments
different cognitive
approaches
a lot of overlap between those different
ways of looking at the emotions
different practices that you would
engage in and they they often would
borrow from each other you know seneca
great example that we've talked about
here on the air a stoic philosopher who
when he's talking with an epicurean
friend of his lucillius he has no
problem quoting epicurus saying well you
know we can go into the enemy camp and
take their take their stuff i don't
remember exactly to take their fire take
their tools whatever it is that they're
getting from from them right
so
if you had to summarize stoicism we've
talked a little bit about
a few things and you've hit on some key
points already what else can we say
about
that stoicism that gives gives people an
idea what's distinctive to it
uh so another thing is that's kind of
also directly counter this idea of like
you know not caring is that uh stoicism
teaches that we are
part of greater wholes that you know uh
we are not a you know
uh
well there's that no man is an island
right yes yes thank you um or like a
single solitary rock you know just
facing the waves it's that we um
as social creatures
uh live in communities that we uh depend
on each other for
uh certain things as well as we because
of these relationships we have certain
duties to other people around us and in
fact that we have a duty to all people
not just those people who are closest to
us yeah that's that's a good way to put
it they often use metaphors of what we
would call social animals like
bees you know for example you know
marcus says what is what is good for the
hive is good for the bee
um and you know if you're a drone who's
mated with the queen and then been
pushed out and left to die for winter
you might say i don't know about that
but you know we
these metaphors can be extended only so
far
but the idea i think it is quite correct
no you know we often say nobody is truly
self-made
um anytime that we find somebody who's
particularly successful there's all
sorts of other people in their
background and factors that came
together in the right place at the right
time to allow the person to make their
contribution but their their
contribution is relying on
an entire fabric of of of others and
recognizing that would be
part of something else that i think we
should talk about in terms of stoicism
it would be part of two particular
virtues
um justice you know recognizing other
people's parts that they've done is only
fair and then wisdom using our minds
correctly and
stoicism um it's not the only philosophy
that talks about virtue but they they
say that
virtue
you know it's not just that virtue is
its own reward
it's that
virtue is what's going to lead us to
happiness but virtue
also is happiness or contentment or
however else we want to to put that that
end state so we should always prioritize
um living a life of the virtues and if
we realize we don't have them
well then we got to work on that right
so that that's a big part of it as well
um
what else do you think we need to say
about for for listeners who don't know
much about stoicism any anything else
come to mind
well the the main thing that comes to
mind is kind of like why are we like we
touch on socialism from time to time
uh but the reason that we're actually
going a little bit deeper into this
today
is that because we are starting a season
of stoicism
um
that's right so september through
november for the international stoic
community you might say wait what
international stoic community nobody
ever told me about this well i mean it's
been building for
the last 20 years
largely because of the internet but
there's like all sorts of books and
literature out there there are local
stoic meeting groups there's all sorts
of cool
online ways to engage people
groups
pages you know and we we also and when i
say we i'm talking about the modern
stoicism organization which you might
also say wait what's that
[Music]
they sponsor a annual stoicon every year
and it used to be held
in you know pretty
um
major metropolitan places like london or
new york or toronto it was held one year
in athens
you know because they wanted to
celebrate philosophy in greece but
last year it went online because of
kovid
and it's being held online as well this
year and we'll probably keep doing that
in the future and everybody's invited
yeah you know uh we've made it as
affordable as as possible
by um you know letting people just make
uh
donations to it and and so it's a cool
event there's lots of speakers all sorts
of local uh groups will be having their
own stoicon x's it's sort of like ted
and tedx
so there's going to be all sorts of
stoic on x events happening through
september all the way to november
there's an international stoic week that
there's like a seven day course that
people can
participate in this will be i think this
will be the 10th year because it started
in 2012
so
that makes it they've successfully done
if we pull it off this year
10 years right
right and that's something i would
highly recommend if anyone's like even
uh tangentially interested in
the topic it's like hey just take a week
you know it doesn't take much there's
like a little morning thing a little
afternoon thing um but just a
a a little dip your toes into what it is
to have a philosophy of life yeah and
the
the data that they've gathered over the
years has uh
shown that for a large proportion of the
people that go through this they have an
increase in their like
uh daily happiness of what they call
like zest which is a number of different
factors all put together yeah and
resilience too being able to
deal with the
the stuff that life throws at you you
know uh we won't say any anything
stronger than stuff but you can come up
with all sorts of
other words on your own that that are
you know a little bit more vociferous
and negative about that i mean so
practicing stoic philosophy will help
with that um and and
dan's right there's data now to to back
that up which is kind of cool you know
yeah that's actually something we should
while we're on the data thing
there is something else that's kind of
interesting there's other studies out
there where they looked at
you know you mentioned the lower case s
stoicism the stiff upper lip you know
stuffing your emotions down all of that
sort of stuff
that actually leads to negative outcomes
that makes people less resilient
practicing actual stoic philosophy what
we're going to be talking about in just
a bit
that leads to better outcomes and so
not only do we know that you know
there's one good good path to take we
also know that the thing that's not
really stoicism but people use the word
for it is bad for you
yeah
so
uh well let's talk so let's talk about
the dichotomy of control because i know
right we mentioned it a little bit
earlier do you want to
give a little
spiel about that about what it means or
uh yes so the dichotomy of control is
there are things that are
in our control and there are things that
are not in our control
um and sometimes people kind of like
okay well i have influence over this
thing or whatnot and the stokes really
make a pretty hard line that there is a
distinction between those things that
are completely within our control
and those things that are even have a
small
monochrome of outside influence and
those things are the things that are not
in our control and so the things that
are in our control
are
our
on
things that we like the things that we
are drawn towards the things that we are
averse to things that you know we push
away
um and our actions towards doing
something so like for example i could
you know be handcuffed and i could want
to raise my hands over my head but i
would be disallowed physically from
doing that but i still i have this
volition to raise my hands over my head
um but
of those things so this is kind of like
a small list of things that are totally
within your control yeah
and the things that are not in your
control are things like wealth health
reputation you cannot will yourself not
to be sick or you can't will yourself to
not die eventually these things are
going to come for you
there are many things that you can do to
make it so that you have a better chance
of
living longer as well as being healthy
but uh to
just say i will not
you know get sick ever or i will not die
is not going to do much for you
yeah that's true um
same thing with money right you can save
your money you can be prudent in what
you spend it on but inflation can erode
it away you know or
somebody could steal it and i mean
that's this we could go on and on we
could do an entire episode about wealth
i think um oh yeah
i do want to point out that stoics also
say that
another set of things that we have
control over what they call a sense and
that's a technical term you could call
it what we agree with or buy into you
know what we co-sign mentally
so if i see
and this can happen both in terms of
like things that present themselves to
me immediately and i buy into it and
also with my reasoning processes or or
my feelings whether they're really
reasonable or not so like if i
somebody's mean to me and
i judge them to have said something
derogatory maybe they actually didn't
but i i judge it to be so then i'm gonna
be negatively affected by that i'm gonna
get maybe hurt or angry
or some other emotion maybe anxious
about it and
the stoics would say you're responsible
for those emotional responses because
you could
you could choose to see things
differently and i think it's very
liberating because many people
believe that our thoughts our emotions
our opinions they're just given to us or
like our body you know does them and we
have no
no control over them at all early you
mentioned desires and aversions i just
like what i like you can ask yourself
well why do you like that you know you
can explore it it's not it's not an
automatic given i mean some things are
seem to be like pretty automatic when
we're kids we like candy but i i
remember taking my daughter
to a
birthday party and they they had a cake
and it was a chocolate cake and one of
the parents said oh my kid doesn't like
chocolate i was like who doesn't like
chocolate you know um well somebody
doesn't and so you know you don't it's
not automatic to the human race that you
must like and desire chocolate i mean
it's pretty compelling but it's uh it's
controllable right so yeah and we should
explore a little bit more of this like
having
influence so if if you don't completely
control something actually okay it could
could i i
would love to jump into that but i want
to kind of delve into that the chocolate
one
uh just the idea of
um
that we are responsible or like we have
control over these things
and
i would extend this into the
you know we
are
wanting to
uh think about this as a process and so
like i know uh i might go into stoicism
and like the
an easy example is like yo people cut
you off in traffic and that you get an
automatic response yeah this twinge of
anger comes up and then and hits you
yeah um and
through time you can
kind of you know reprogram or re train
yourself away from these judgments and
so it's not like oh i'm going to take up
stoicism and all of a sudden all these
things that they say are outside are
like that are
are you know passing things that are um
you know within my control that are like
causing me it's not gonna like
immediately happen yeah yeah and that
these things um
you know you
you'll still have these
emotions arise and i and you know the
stokes do break down the emotion to
three different parts the the
impression the immediate thing that
comes to mind um the the place in which
you can actually sit there and examine
that and either ascending or descenting
to that emotion so like this is really
simple like you tell your kids like you
get angry count to ten
right right so it gives you that space
to just go why am i angry and think
about that and like because i had some
judgment about that thing and that that
person thinks that that was a bad and
the strokes would say like these things
are usually not bad
um
and and the the real bad thing is the
way that you're going to be reacting to
these things yeah
that's that's that's a good point um
it helps you to
and
you're right it doesn't there's it's not
like flipping a switch where well i read
a stoic book and now everything falls
into place
right even i think even on a cognitive
level there's some things that in when
you're reading the stoics unless you're
actually practicing for a while some of
those things don't really
make sense completely you know right
like with any any any um
intentional way of living
but but yeah it does it does uh provide
a bit of
possibility for liberation i wanted to
go back though to the um okay the things
that we don't completely control
maybe something else is running the show
like just physical processes or you know
what the stoics would call fate but a
lot of times it's other people
who don't have complete control over
that thing
but
they do have some power over it so if i
really want to be
uh recognized by everybody as an
important person you know if we
so so we're going to use some milwaukee
metaphors here right we have a guy
called the milverine
and you've met him right i think at one
point or another i'm not okay but you've
seen him i i haven't actually seen him
um and and you know he looks like
wolverine the comic book character but
he's from milwaukee and he
he moves around and does things and um
you know mostly he's he's known for
walking everywhere that he goes and he
never wears a shirt yeah that's right
yeah because he's very hairy right yes
so so if i decide
actually that furnish is a really great
example if i decide as a non-hairy chest
guy
who's also not as built as that guy
either and probably doesn't have the
hair to pull it off and i don't think i
could get my beard to be as bushy as his
that i want to replace him
and become the new
whatever we're going to co maybe him the
milwaukee saber-tooth or something
i thought would you be the milwaukee
dude but okay okay well there you go
yeah i mean maybe i should like as they
say stay in your lane right yes um so so
we'll shift to that i decide that i want
to be like the character of the dude
which some people say that i i look like
um and so i i put on the
um
what would i call it the diet the
dialect that he has oh well i have the
sweater right yeah and i could i could
easily get the kind of stuff i just wear
a dirty t-shirt and shorts and
flip-flops and walk around right
and i start saying like that's your
opinion man and things like that
there's no guarantee that i'm going to
be able to pull it off even if i'm
really trying because other people can
say no i don't think he's the dude at
all you know it's not a very good
impression it's actually this is another
kind of funny thing i think we might
have talked about this on air there are
celebrities
who
um
they go
into like a crowd of people who are
impersonating them and people say you're
not a very good impersonator of
this person or that person or this
person get out of here
you know and now what this points out is
so much of social life is is pretty
arbitrary and if we allow ourselves to
get too
drawn into it and and make the measure
of our happiness or success that we pull
these things off
it's just not going to happen it's like
you know epictetus talks about this
musician
who can play his instrument really well
but he doesn't control what the crowd
does and if he if he takes the crowd's
applause as an index for him being a
good musician he's going to be
filled with anxiety because you you just
can't control that you know and you
might say well i can do things and those
should make things happen yeah go ahead
and try that because
you know the stoics will say you'll find
out real quick just how little control
you have over those matters now this
leads us to another point if you don't
have any control over those matters
shouldn't you just like withdraw
completely from them and say
i'm not gonna play that that crooked
game i'm i'm gonna take my my pieces and
go home or pick up my ball and walk away
so this hole reminds me like you know
you can like you're you're aficionado of
metal but some people really don't like
metal that's right and so if if you go
to a like the philharmonic
and you put on a metal show
the audience there's you you might be
the best metal band in the world yeah
and you are still going to get
potentially booed um
so you you find your audience and uh
like
or you
you know if you if you need like this is
the audience the only audience and like
either you you define like what you want
to make and if you if like metal is the
thing that you got to make then you make
that medal um kind of regardless of that
outcome um and but if you're like you
know
your goal is to have the adoration the
crowd uh
you might do things that would
uh lead you to have a better chance
but there's always that chance and it's
not going to be in your control that's a
really great example that i think we can
draw some other analogies to and and
it's it's not just the
applause or adoration of the crowd per
se it's this crowd right so if you want
um
people who are more likely to appreciate
what you're doing go go play at um shank
hall you know
where metal bands play local metal bands
um
that would make a lot more sense than
trying to go to the milwaukee symphony
and walk out on stage and start
shredding right unless they've invited
you to do that and and you know we could
say this with so many things you know
when somebody has a bad breakup we often
say things like oh you know there's many
other fish in the sea
and that's right you know there's
nothing that says that your affection
and capacity to love has to be met by
this particular person
and if you can if you can like withdraw
from where things clearly aren't lining
up
that enables you to start looking
elsewhere and we could say this about
job stuff i mean maybe some people
aren't suited for certain jobs and they
make themselves miserable by insisting
on pushing that you know we have that
expression the the uh what is the square
peg in the round hole or is it the round
peg in the square hole i mean either one
doesn't work right right yeah and and a
lot of jobs i think are sort of like
that i actually see that sometimes with
uh
people who have the wrong major in
college and they're like well you know
it's junior year and i've already got
these credits in and they're miserable
and you're like
do you want to go and become this and
they're like not really but
i'm i'm there and and you know i think
the following
fallacy well you need to explain that a
little bit okay so some cost fallacies
you know the the fact that we often
throw good money after bad and whenever
we like either make an investment in
either you know money or time or any
other particular
uh external good
we can
say like well i've already done i'm like
you know i'm in for a penny in for a
pound type thing
um but if you were to like stop and say
okay i'm starting from point zero does
it make any point more sense
to
continue down like to
put money into this investment either
time or whatever um and if the answer is
no then doesn't matter what you've spent
already uh
any extra money that you're putting in
there is just you know good money after
bad you know it's interesting because
we're gonna talk about emotions soon
and i think that um
there you can you can bring up a couple
different emotions one reason why people
stick with
sunk costs particularly if there's like
conflict involved with it and we're
seeing this in terms of people's
politics right now
is
shame they would much rather stick to a
uh a false narrative about how things
happened and who's it to blame then
admit that they were wrong because
admitting that they're wrong especially
after they've been in conflict with
other people means
feeling embarrassment or shame and there
that that fear can keep people glued
there epictetus also says something
really interesting in one of his
discourses that petitus the great stoic
philosopher
he's talking about a guy
who
has decided to do something and i don't
remember exactly what stupid thing he
decided to do
but he's saying i'm being a stoic
because i'm being resolute i'm sticking
with the thing and nobody's going to
influence me and epictetus says hold on
buddy we've got to back up one step
is the thing that you decided to do
reasonable if it's not reasonable and
you're just sticking to it that's not
stoicism that's stubbornness that's
obstinacy
and and i think you know sometimes
people get there you know they get that
emotional comportment where nobody's
going to move them and that's not that's
not really stoicism because to to be
stoic means to
um live in accordance with our nature
and that is a rational nature and that
that that's a good segue into the next
thing we're going to talk about which is
um it's not just a rational nature it's
a social nature right right so we're
social
creatures with a capacity for reason
kind of depends on how much we actually
use that capacity or how much we
uh build it but we do have that capacity
that's true i think a lot of people when
they hear that we're rational creatures
they assume that rationality is like an
all or nothing thing too
and it's definitely not i mean
we're born with a great potential for
developing as rational creatures but i
don't know if any of us ever
fully
develop and deploy that i mean i do i do
dumb stuff myself and i'm you know i
mean i i should be
pretty well along since i've been
studying philosophy and teaching for a
long time
presumably if philosophy helps you out
to be more rational than at 51 years old
i should be you know pretty rational but
you know
we all we all have these pockets and
then the question is well do we like
hide them away or do we
do we try to work on that do we
recognize where we need to to do more
and i don't think that i've never met
anybody who i would consider like
totally completely rational all the time
have you
no and this is why i think
a lot of like economic theory is is
pretty
funny because they kind of like
basically they make that assumption yeah
all humans are perfectly rational
they're always going to like get like
the the best
um the most things for them but there's
so many things that are uh out there
that will you know that we make
decisions about that are not in our best
like financial interest
yeah
yeah we and we often i mean i think this
is another thing we could explore at
great length there's a difference
between like reasoning and
rationalization you know rationalization
is what people do after they've made a
decision and they're trying to look for
some some plausible reasoning process
for it and you know some people will go
for anything reasoning means that you
actually like try to seek out the truth
and you're probably willing to change
your mind to some degree
if factors change or somebody brings up
a good point and this goes back to the
social nature thing i mean how do you
figure out when you've got things wrong
sometimes you can figure it out by you
know you put your finger in the mouse
trap and you realize pretty quickly that
by the pain inflicted on you that that
was a dumb decision
but there's so many things where we
really need other people to come along
and say
you're screwing up man uh take a look at
this you know and and maybe that's part
of our social nature as well
the correct ability you might say of
human human nature
yeah there's there's so many
other things and it comes down to this
idea that we are social creatures yeah
that um a lot of times we will make
bad logical deductions and reasoning
um or rationalization in order to make
sure that we maintain our
uh reputation within that social group
and so this is one of the things that
stoicism tries to like put forth is that
like
our uh
reputation is not a good in and of
itself and that we should try to
remove that from our the basis of our
reasoning in
choosing the good uh uh
virtuous decision and the action that
follows you know we can say that about
pretty much all of the things that the
stoics consider to be
and we're going to use a technical term
here indifference not meaning that they
don't have any value at all but they
should be valued less than
the genuine good which is
you know
moral goodness virtue which includes
wisdom
i think you could say that about wealth
a lot of people make bad decisions on
the basis which they rationalize on the
basis of you know trying to protect
their
income or their property
we can say this about pleasure
you know pleasure is something or the
prospect of pleasure can easily lead us
into making bad decisions
power
authority positions those sorts of
things people will often
really stick their necks out in ways
they want for wealth to get a little
power over somebody else
um
so yeah that's that that's quite true
um
so the stokes are here to try to find us
a place where we can
you know live
in accordance with like both of these
natures that you know we're we're
wanting to be part of this group and how
do we
interact with people in a just way like
the way that they ought to be treated as
well as
i'm not sacrificing those things that
are actually the goods they are
moral actions here
and
these
things
usually sometimes like people because
they have different ideas of what we
call these indifference as actual goods
these things come into conflict and the
stoics are saying like there's two
levels of things
and and the virtues are are
up here and everything else is down here
doesn't mean you know as you said it
doesn't mean that they don't have value
but uh none of these things can really
be traded for those things up here these
virtues yeah so to take an example it's
it's better to have some
financial resources than to be
impoverished and the stoics wouldn't say
don't manage your money wisely you know
you actually should do that but no
amount of wealth that you accumulate and
no amount of good decisions with
your wealth is going to make you into a
good person you can be
a vicious person in many other respects
and be filthy rich
money doesn't make the
morality you could say and we could say
the same thing about power having a nice
body i mean if you have a body as we all
do if you don't you're dead
i don't know how you'd be listening to
this if you don't have a body um you
know you should take care of it you
shouldn't like
abuse it
um you should probably wash it every so
often give it some exercise
put the right kind of things into it you
know
try to minimize putting bad things into
it but
you know that that's not going to make
you into a good person you go to the gym
there's plenty of jerks at the gym you i
mean you can tell they're the ones who
pick up the uh the cleaner bottle and
they they take it with them because
they're selfish
they're the ones that don't don't clean
off the the the exercise equipment when
they're done with it because they
they're lazy or you know pick whatever
else you want right
right they might have very nice looking
bodies but
that doesn't doesn't make him uh great
so that's that that's uh that's a great
um
thing to focus on how does that pertain
then
to this mistaken idea of the stoic as
withdrawing themselves from other people
so i wanted to say like you know if you
don't believe that we are like social
creatures
uh
the idea of solitary confinement is like
considered in many parts of the world to
be torture because removing ourselves
like without our will away from other
people's is
uh highly detrimental to our mental
well-being
um and and part of this is because you
know to be ostracized
is uh gives us a similar feeling to the
dread of death as you know we as humans
as uh tribal peoples before we really
started sitting down and doing like
agriculture and whatnot um being removed
from the group was
basically equivalent to death it was
very hard for you to survive without the
group um and that is that is really
built into our our core psychology here
yeah and it's still used by some
uh groups as a mode of punishment
shunning banishing disfellowing you know
can really do a number on on a person
especially if they're heavily invested
in that that particular group and they
don't know how to
make those sort of connections elsewhere
i mean you know you know in another
respect when people are forced out of
their workplace
you know
they're made redundant they're laid off
um that's
often quite psychologically devastating
to people because they that would be
part of their
their little
um clan or tribe or whatever they're
part of right
right and you know because we define
on ourselves a lot of times by the
groups that we are part of
and we
you know
uh realize our own human nature in
you know the
interactions and the camaraderie that we
have with the groups
and so this kind of kind of reminds me
of this idea of done bars number which
is like about 150.
it's the the number of people the people
that
a group can maintain
with fairly close sensations before it
either um disintegrates or splits okay
and so uh it's it's really hard to have
uh more than 150 close friends and we're
not talking facebook friends
yeah some people have the the full
complement of 5000 on facebook right
right
um and
but we as as humans have this like
special ability that we've developed as
a like a psychological tool of creating
um
categories for us to belong to which
supersedes these dunbar numbers and so
okay um instead of like sticking with
like a tribe of up to 150 people um we
decided like oh well we can like all
call ourselves
you know a citizen of this state or we
can all call ourselves a member of this
religion or we can all call you know
whatever like group and even though
we don't know that per
group or that uh those people
specifically like
we can say fandoms like i'm right now
i'm in north carolina and if i see
someone with a packer hat on i'm gonna
go up and talk to him actually i saw a
guy with a uh
uh a bucks uh shirt at a trader joe's
the other day and i struck up a
conversation with him because you know
what we had something in common we were
part of this group even though like i've
never met him madam it's funny because
uh i don't know the bucks equivalent of
this but packer nation right
and it exists spread out throughout the
entire i mean it exists in other places
but the entire united states any major
city
you can go on game day and find a
bar
where the packers game will be playing
and when you walk in this is actually
something that that my wife andy
observed in new york city where people
are you know kind of
you know they might put on airs about
talking like a midwesterner and so they
come in
uh
off the street and they it's a place
called kettle of fish and at first
they're kind of relating to each other
as new yorkers new yorkers that that are
of a certain you know type and and sort
and then after a while all the yacht or
hey language comes out you know and
everything don't you know exactly
you know because they they gel that way
um so yeah that's that's that's a good
example as a matter of fact that's a
good segue too to talk about emotions
because people often get quite emotional
about sport and
you know a lot of people have this
mistaken notion about stoicism that it
means like turning off the emotions
almost like if you're turning off a
a water flow or just stuffing them down
or you know trying to ignore them as
much as possible
and that's clearly not what classic
stoics taught or thought right
right and we've already touched about
this a little bit in the the breaking up
of the emotion
um but yeah like the the stokes were
reportedly like the ancient ones rather
jovial individuals yeah friendly you
could yeah right they had fun
um right it was a chrysippus who's
supposed to have died
uh laughing at at a funny site i mean he
was an old guy so uh it was something
about a donkey and i don't quite
remember exactly what happened but you
know
they they didn't have a lack of a sense
of humor and they
loved other people
and so it's it's the exact opposite here
like the stokes are not about
uh stuffing down these emotions but to
more
fully understand them to be so close to
them that you are not taken away by them
that you you know them intimately and
why
you have these emotions arising in the
first place
yeah so a good example of this is one
that they they didn't have any positive
role for as such but we all run into
sooner or later loss or grief right
i mean
this is kind of morbid to say this but
everybody that you know they're either
going to die before you or die or you're
going to die before them or you're going
to die at the same time
so sooner or later like you know you and
i are friends
if we're friends long enough we'll one
of us will go to the other's funeral
and you know presumably you you miss
people and and all that and the stoics
would say well you're it's it's not
human to not miss people or to not feel
sad but that doesn't mean you have to as
people did in ancient times like tear
your beard out
or wear black for a year or rip your
clothes or you know sometimes people
these days like they they jump on the
coffin as it's going down into the grave
that's that's that's not serving anybody
anything and it's not a sign that you
actually love them
maybe the sign would be like seneca says
you go out and find new friends
to replace the ones that you've lost
wouldn't wouldn't your friend want that
uh for you
the stoics also thought they were
positive emotions and among those they
included
love affection
concern for others care
these are these are not things that
we should be avoiding but we we should
be avoiding doing them in the wrong way
so right
you know if you think about concern for
somebody there's like there's being
concerned where
you take prudent steps to help them out
and then there's the like being a worry
wart where you're getting you're getting
more out of like the appearance of being
concerned or or um you know occupying
yourself with needless worries and the
stokes says well that that's
counterproductive get rid of that you
know right so making those distinctions
between positive and
less productive
emotional states i think would be an
important part of stoicism
and once again this these are things
that one works on these aren't just a
various switch type things yeah yeah
um and yeah you're right you know some
of them you don't get the
opportunity to work on them
every day unless unless you do some
exercises
uh right so grief i mean hopefully you
don't have somebody dying every single
day in your life right um
but if you've had a recent loss you can
think about how you're dealing with it
each day i suppose
um
what are some other examples of emotions
that you can work on bit by bit by bit
um
let's see uh hopefully like greed and
like okay kind of ruminating on on what
is is it actually a good if you have
this avarice towards
these things and like trying to reorient
yourself towards the things that are
actually good okay um
i was thinking about just the the losing
people and you can like there's the
uh negative visualization which we've
spoken about in the past
talking about how we can like think
about okay i'm going to think about like
i know that eventually one of my loved
ones is going to die and maybe i can
stem this a little bit by thinking about
how i would react to it and try to kind
of experience
a small portion of that in order to kind
of inoculate you against the the
the rush the like the tidal wave that
kind of hits us when you know people
pass away especially if it's sudden
that's a great example of something
going back to the beginning of our
conversation where the stoics differed
from the epicureans
the epicureans would say why dwell on
negative stuff you know
you should have as pleasant to life as
possible so don't think about people
dying
before they do you'll you'll get to
think about that when they do die you
know
just enjoy yourself for right now but
but a stoic would say well this will
help me handle things better when they
actually do pass away
um or
not them but somebody else
right yeah
uh
let's talk about some of the other
emotions that you mentioned a little bit
so
doesn't care for others make us
vulnerable to things that aren't in our
control doesn't that
disadvantage us in a certain way
um but don't you also gain advantages
from
you know having those relationships this
is yeah the things that you have to give
and take it kind of
remains reminds me of the
on the end of the gem wow the return of
the jedi okay uh luke is in the throne
room of the emperor and the emperor is
uh saying
um like your your friends are your
downfall and luke is recording like no
i've been friends with the reason that
i'm able to move through and um
eventually surmount this obstacle yeah
i don't it's been a long time since i've
seen the movie but doesn't the emperor
also like when he when he sees that luke
has beaten his father darth vader
doesn't he say okay
um
that's fine now you can become my my new
apprentice right take your dad's place
he's dead to me you know yeah something
like that
[Music]
and it shows you how i guess little they
cared for those relationships they were
just tools and not something to actually
cultivate and care for
yeah that's a great point we often talk
about this as treating people
instrumentally or as a mere means
to something else you can't really love
somebody or respect them or care for
them as a person if you're
if there isn't at least some treating
them as if they mattered
right that's you're
bringing in a little comp there uh that
one should always treat someone as
um and ends and never merely as a means
yeah yeah that was i mean that was a
great way that he articulated it i think
there's there's this is a total
digression there's there's a lot of
things where i like reading kant but i'm
like well i don't think this is true at
all
i think i think he got that one right
yeah
um
you know so go ahead please
i was going to say another another thing
that we want to talk about is
our attachments to our our friends and
families
um and other people that we care about
it might be people people at work it
might be
clients it might be other people
and we can we can take this uh
attachment that we do in fact have and
experience some of us more some of us
less
and extend it to all sorts of other
people who we might end up being
connected with or
being involved with or or caring for
and
i think stoicism would tell us we have
to be realistic about these and we're
going to talk about a practice that
ties in with this you know human beings
are
vulnerable to all sorts of
damage whether psychological or physical
they're not going to last forever
we're all living off of warranty you
could say
right we're all on borrowed time and
most people are not going to be stoics
even if we are so
we can't expect them to
have the same sort of resiliency if
we're practicing it that that um
you know we could we could have um and
we we also have a whole as you mentioned
earlier we have a whole set of whatever
we want to call them duties appropriate
actions those are the stoic terms for
this we might think of them as
moral
responsibilities some of these are more
stringent or strict or
or they have a higher priority than
others
but
you know when we pass somebody
on the street they're not nothing
and if we can help them out the stoics
would say we we ought to do that and
this can be furthered by
having the right kind of feelings
or trying to cultivate the right kind of
feelings maybe faking the funk until we
can actually feel it
um
[Music]
so this comes to like the kind of the
basis of the idea of
justice for stoicism and so justice is
this kind of this large category of
things it's not just like you know what
happens the courthouse but it is also
all
all those things that one ought to
interact with other people for
um like uh i ought not to call you bad
names
partly because you're another human so i
shouldn't be doing that in the first
place also especially because you're my
friend and friends don't tend to do that
to each other yeah uh and so we have
like levels of
obligations that we have based on our
roles to other people and so like i
would have um different obligations to
my significant other than i have to you
and i have different obligations that i
have to my parents than i have to my
significant other yeah
we should mention too that um justice is
a virtue for the stoics so this is a
character trait that we it's not
optional it's something that we ought to
have
um and so again to go back to our
original theme of stoicism doesn't mean
withdrawing from everybody else this is
this is part of what it means to be a
social being you you connect with
all these other people and you try to do
do right by them and and by yourself
um there's there's another side to
justice and i just want to hit on this
quick because i do want to get us to
this practice that we'll discuss
the stoics didn't just mean like not
violating people's rights or honoring
your agreements or following the rules
by justice they are super clear that
justice includes kindness and
beneficence and whatever else you want
to call it being good to other people
that's that's a part of justice for them
right so let's
go ahead
but
it's uh justin right for us to go to his
practice here at the moment
on good segway
so so epictetus tells us we won't read
the whole thing but in encouraging or
the handbook number three in everything
that pleases the soul or supplies a want
or is loved remember to add this to the
notion what what is the nature of each
thing if you
love uh an earthen vessel say it's an
earthen vessel because that when it's
broken you're not going to be disturbed
if you're kissing a child or a wife say
that it's a human being who you're
kissing from when the wife or child dies
you will not be disturbed now that
sounds rather cold doesn't it
right how can we use this in a way that
isn't
being cold and withdrawing from other
people i mean epictetus says
if you do love people and so he's
assuming that you are being loving
towards them
um
we don't have to demand of the world
things that it can't give like my wife
living forever i mean i'd love if she
could
provided i could too
um but even even if i couldn't i'd still
wish that for her but the world isn't
going to give us that
right
now to be to love and also be aware of
the limitations of us as finite beings
that's a good way to put it yeah yeah
that uh
we
will lose people and we will have to
live on and how does one continue to do
the things that are required of us
even
when we lose those that we love
so we were joking before we got on that
my my cat who's almost 19 years old is
doing quite well and uh we were talking
about this uh practice and and dan said
you should whisper into her ear every
time that you you hold her you know you
are a cat and you you are immortal you
will die
that's you know a little over the top
but we could do something like that
couldn't we remind ourselves of that
remind ourselves
in some ways we we have more when we do
that we
honor the relationship
we
also work better for it because we knew
we know that this is a finite thing this
won't always be and so the time is now
yeah
well that's a good place to leave off
with uh these reflections do you want to
lead us out on pithy quote
yeah so today we leave you with the
words of aristotle
at his best
man is the noblest of all animals
separated from law and justice
he is the worst
[Music]
[Music]
you